Yeah so today I want to show you these funky
laser cut wooden tiles. You can see they all have
different patterns, different squiggles, they're
cut out in different sizes. I'm hopefully going
to teach you a fun game that you can play with
them. Before we get to the tile part you may or
may not know this game we're going to start
with: Set. This is a card game, it's beloved by
mathematicians everywhere in the world. It was
actually invented in 1974 by Marsha Falco who
was a geneticist - so not a mathematician. And she
invented it while studying epilepsy in German
shepherds which is very cool. I want to take just
a moment to explain the rules. So if we look at
the deck here, these cards are not like normal
playing cards; and if we wanted to describe them
you might notice that there are four characteristics
that we need to describe. So each card has a color;
each card has a number of objects on it; each card
has an object with a certain shape and each object
has a shading. So what are the options? If I tell
you there are three then we can see what they are.
Every card is either purple, green or red. Numbers,
again there's three options: so we could have one
object, we could have two objects, or we could have
three objects - all the same you'll notice, there's
only one type of object per card. Then shape we
could have this oval, we could have squiggle, or we
could have a diamond. And then the shading we could
have it be empty, we could have it have stripes,
or our last option is it could be solid. And so
in this table now we have exactly one card for
every combination. So for each card you can only
have one characteristic per quality and so there
are 81 cards total.
- (Brady: Let's see your shuffling skills)
- No no no no. You and I are playing
a game; well first you're gonna lose - I'm justkidding.
- (Oh no; you're gonna- I'm gonna lose?)
- 12 cards
I didn't do a great job shuffling
but we're gonna go with it.
Okay and so then we need our definition. Sowhat
we're looking for is a set, is a collection
of three cards such that in each category the
cards are either all the same or all different.
So what that's saying is that in each of
the four categories you either have one of
each option where they all match. And it doesn't
have to be the same for each category; you could
have a purple card, a green card, a red card that
all have one oval open and that would be a set.
Or you could have more variants; so let's see if
you can find a set here.
- (Okay so and- and you and I)
(normally we would be racing to see-)
- Racing exactly, right exactly.
- (But we're not racing?)
- No I'm gonna
let you have all the time you need.
- (So like forexample these three here that have three ovals,)
(would they be a set? Or are they- are they-)?
- So let'slook at these threee. So they're not going to
be a set. They're good on the oval, so there's
three ovals, they all have three and they all
have different shadings; but the color is a problem.
Because they're neither all the same nor all different.
- (Ah so it's got to)
(be multiple colours? I'm with you, I'm with you, all right.)
- Exactly, exactly
- (Oh well that's not- it's not as easy as I thought then)
No. Now I'll tell you there is a set
on the board, I've found one.
- (Let me- well how about-)
(Oh no, that's not a set
because we've got two lots of three)
(Okay? Is that right?)
- No, that's not a set
because there's two threes yeah, exactly. There's a-
- (Yeh I see why that fails.)
There's at least two sets on the board.
- (Okay. I'vegot a good feeling about this one.)
- Mm-hmm
(That, that, that. So I think that's a set because we've got
a three, three, three. So we've got a set on the number criteria)
They're all the same.
- (A red, red, red)
- Allthe same.
- (All the same. We've got three different)
(shapes so there's no shapes the same;
and solid, solid, solid.)
- Perfect! That's
a set.
- (Okay so in the game I would then keep
them)
- You would keep them and we'd deal
out three more cards and then you go again.
I think different types of sets pop out to
different types of people. So I often find much
faster sets where all three colors are different.
For some reason it's just easier for me to find
those; versus the one you found is all three red
cards. And so I think it really varies by what
sets pop out to what people. Now if you play
this game, especially with mathematicians, it can
get a little obnoxious how fast people are. I am
actually not that fast of a Set player, I'm just a
big trash talker, and so part of the goal today is
to show you some harder versions of this game
that slow everybody down.
- (Hang on, before we go)
(Give us another set from that group.)
- Give us another? Oh gosh I'm so bad at this. Okay
- my sister's gonna laugh at how long this
takes me - okay so this is another set. So it's
a similar flavor to the one you found; all the
same color, all the same number, different shape,
all the same shading. I would say that these two
sets are kind of the same flavor set so let's
see if we can find one with different colors.
So here's one where we have different colors,
and you'll notice I found it much faster. We have
three different colors, three different shapes, all
one, and three different shadings. So this one has
more variance than these the two sets do somehow.
(Nice. All right I get- cool game.)
- Yeah. So part of why mathematicians love this game,
beyond it being a really fun game to play, there
is a lot of really cool math behind it and a lot
of questions that we can ask. So we're not going to
dive into that aspect - there's a lot of papers you
could go read about it. But for example we could
say, must there always be a set if we deal out 12
cards? Right? Because theoretically there could be a
set or there could not be a set. And that's a very
famous question in mathematics; it turns out until
you deal out 21 cards there doesn't necessarily
need to be a set present. And you can also ask
questions about how many sets are there - all types
of things. And so to explore any of these types
of questions we want to impose some structure
on this game mathematically. And so the way we do
it is that we're going to have a funky numbering
system. The mathematical term; we might say it's
a sort of modular arithmetic, or finite field. The
basic idea is that we assign a 0, a 1 and a
2 arbitrarily to our rows of characteristics. So
arbitrarily we say that purple's 0, having one
is a 0, oval 0, open a 0. And so on and
so forth for 1 and 2. But we impose this funny
rule that 1 plus 1 plus 1 is actually equal
to 0 in this arithmetic. So for example if I add
1 plus 1 then I get 1; but if I add 1 plus
2 plus 2 then I would normally get 5 but
every time we see 3 we cancel it out so this
is actually equal to 2. It's modular arithmetic
exactly, mod 3. And so with this, now for a
card well we can assign to it a 4-tuple, a
vector where we put in the number corresponding to
the character. So let's do this card here. So this
card is red so its color entry is a 2, because
red is 2, and then there are two of them so what
number comes next? That's a 1 and then we have
squiggle so it's a 1 again and its shading is
stripe so it's a 1 again. So we would call this
card the 2-red-squiggle-stripes; the vector or
the 4-tuple (2,1,1,1). And so this this
will now give us a nice space that we can study
and we often say that this would live in like
F(3,4). So this is just the 3 here
is reminding us that we're working mod 3 and the
4 is saying that we have four qualities. So
we have now this dictionary right, so we have our
cards that we described using these English words
and we now have a tuple. And so what's cool about
this math system is that a set will correspond
to three vectors or quadruples in F sub 3
to the 4 that sum to 0. And why is this
the case? Well if we think about what it means to
be all different, right, then that means you have
a 0, a 1, and a 2 showing up in that entry
of your vector; and in our special math 0 plus
1 plus 2 is 3 which we've said is 0.
And if you're all the same then you either look
like 0 plus 0 plus 0 which is 0; 1
plus 1 plus 1 is equal to 0; or 2 plus
2 plus 2 is equal to 0. So if you're all
the same in a category then you also get a zero in
that entry when you add your your vectors across.
And so we get this really nice correspondence
mathematically where if you want to know what
a set is then you're really looking for three
vectors in this space that's up to zero. Just to be
clear when I say zero I mean (0,0,0,0).
So the vector length is four- four entries for our
four characteristics but a card gives- corresponds
to one vector. So if we want three cards where all
the characteristics are the same or different then
that means we have three vectors where each entry
of the vector sums to zero. Okay so the one you
found, so we have- so let's do our tuple. So what's
this card? Well we have red and then we have 3
and then we have oval and we have solid. We again
have red, again have 3, now we have diamond
and then we have solid. And then we have red, 3,
squiggle, solid. So now we sum these - the way that we
sum across a vector is that we sum each entry. So
2 plus 2 plus 2 is 6 but that's a multiple
of 3 so that gives us a 0. Again 2 plus
2 plus 2 gives us 0. 0 plus 2 plus
1 - well we had that case here, we get 0 and
2 plus 2 plus 2 is 0. I'm being a little
sloppy with my equal sign here, I'm saying equal in
this in this space.
- (If you had special goggles that
let you see the cards as their vectors rather than)
(as they appear, would that make the game easier
or harder?)
- That's a great question; and so actually
I think this is part of why mathematicians
love this game is that you actually can think
about it in terms of the cards, you can think about-
I would say this is an algebraic interpretation. So
we're thinking about it in terms of algebra. Or
you could actually think about it in terms of
geometry, where in fact if we lined up for example
all of the red cards that are diamonds then you
could notice that sets are exactly the lines
showing up in that space. And so we actually
have another definition that's equivalent. So to
answer your question I think it probably depends
on who's playing; some people are probably really
fast at the algebra, some people might be really
fast with geometry. I do think at the end of the
day that the cards are often the most fun way to
play. And so I'll talk about this a little bit
with these new variations of the game, but what
you're really looking for is a game that is fun to
play and interesting mathematically. All right so
now I want to talk about some generalizations
of this game that I actually invented with
two friends when I was in grad school. So the
friends are Jonah Ostroff and Lucas Van Meter.
We just- we love this game and we're very
competitive so we like to find new harder versions
of the game. How can we generalize this game to
other mathematical structures? So if we think back
to our to our original game, right, then we said
we were over this F 3 to the 4 - that's kind of
our structure. What do we need to make Set - and I'll
put in quotes because I mean with other structures.
The first thing we need is we need some collection
of elements; we need some cards. So in this case the
elements are these 4-tuples with the numbers
0, 1 and 2 and our cards are normal Set
cards. We need some way to combine our elements. In
our normal Set game we took our two vectors and we
could add them component wise. And so if you give
me two cards I have a mathematical way to combine
them. So in whatever elements we come up with, we
need a way to combine them. Then we need some sort
of target where- something we're trying to get to.
So again a normal game, where we're trying to get
to is (0, 0, 0, 0) - that's what we're trying
to add our elements to. So this is some type of
target element we could think of it as an identity
or zero depending on what type of elements you're
working with. And then lastly we want to know that
for any two elements there is a way to get to the
target right? Because if you've picked two cards
and there wasn't a third card that could complete
the set it wouldn't make the game very fun. So bare
bones this is kind of the minimal list of things
we need; and in math we might say one one structure
that satisfies this if we took a group. So a group
has some sort of elements, it has an operation
that allows you to combine your elements, it has
an identity element, and you can always- if you pick
a group element you can always find a way back to
the identity. So what I want to talk about for the
rest of the time are different groups that we can
play Set on - and there are actually a lot of them.
But today we're going to talk about a specific
type of group, it's called a permutation group.
I'm now going to explain to you what these funky
lines are, and so they're actually corresponding
to permutations. So what do I mean by a permutation?
Well we're going to simplify things and we're just
going to say we're looking at some collection of
numbers, integers, 1 to some number n but we'll
just say 3. So 1, 2, 3 and a permutation
is a bijective map between these sets. So it means
that every number on the left gets mapped to
exactly one number on the right; and in particular
that means that every number on the right will be
mapped to by exactly one number on the left. So for
example we could send 1 to 1, 2 to 2, 3
to 3. So that's kind of a boring permutation.
Amore interesting one might be we could send 1 to
2, 2 to 1, 3 to 3. So these are going
to be our elements, so our elements are going to
be these maps between sets of numbers. And so
this group in particular we might call S sub
3 because we're looking at three numbers here.
And so now I said we need to build a combined
permutation; so if this is our first permutation
how can we combine it with another one? Well we
just do what's most natural and we concatenate
them. And then for a second permutation 1 goes
to 2, 2 goes to 3, and 3 goes up to 1.
So then if we want to combine them we just trace
along the line completely, and so we'd say well
1 first goes to 2 and then 2 goes to 3
so 1 ends up going all the way down to 3. 2
goes up to 1, 1 goes down to 2 so 2 goes to
itself. And then 3 goes to 3 and 3 goes up to 1.
We now have elements, we have a way to combine them,
I wrote down our target and you'll just have to
believe me for now that for any two elements we
can always find a way back to our target. And it
comes from the fact that these are going to be
groups. Okay so now the punch line here is that we
can play this game; and so on each of these cards
you have one of these permutations that show
up. And so now the way we play Set is that
you're looking for some combination of three
that when you put them together you get back the
identity permutation. But what's interesting
about this version is that order matters. So if you
think back to our original there's no ordering on
these cards, but there is an ordering for here. So
once we deal them out you have to find a subset
in this order that compose the identity. So if
we take these two - so one, okay so it's going to be
this one. When we compose these three together you
can trace your finger along the 1 it goes down
and back up, down it comes back up, 3 it goes
up and then back down. So this is what we would
call a set in this game.
- (What are the red dots)
(down the bottom there?)
- That's a great question. So
the red dots at the bottom correspond to whether
or not we can write this as an even or odd number
of swapping of lines. So there's a lot of theory
behind these types of elements and so it just
helps- for example you can prove that any set
here has to have an even number of red dots. So it
helps you when you're trying to find them because
it's much harder in this game.
- (I want the lines- the
position of the start point of the lines-)
To start and end.
- (to start and end in the same spot.)
- That's whatyou want, that's your identity.
(Yeah okay. Well thatsounds hard)
- It is hard. And to tell you the truth
this one is quite easy because there's only three
lines. So let me show you the tiles now. We can do
this for a lot of different sets of permutations.
So on these cells you'll notice they have four
positions, 1 to 4 instead of 1 to 3; and
it makes the game much harder. So with just three
starting and ending spots you have six cards; with
four start and ending spots you have 24 cards. So
these are laser cut and you'll notice the wedge at
the bottom- isolate this one right, you'll notice
there's a notch here and it's the same reason
that you can write this permutation as exactly
swapping two lines. So we have this one is harder
to see but you could write this one as well as an
odd number of line swapping, so it has a wedge. And
so the way we play is we deal out, that imposes
an ordering on our tiles, and then we're looking
for a subset. Now we play - this game's made up so
you can play however you like - but we play three
or more tiles, it's very restrictive to say you
have to have exactly three tiles. So for example,
so these five tiles which you'll notice I kept
the order the same, we can trace our finger, 1
goes down to the spot 3, up to 2, down to 4,
up to 2, back up to 1. 2 goes up to 1, across,
down, down, up. And so you can trace across that you
do in fact have the identity permutation across
all five tiles.
- (It feels to me like you've made
the hardest game ever. Like I feel like I would)
(look- I would look at a bunch of those tiles and
it would take me a year in my head to- to make)
(those paths.)
- Yeah so this is actually probably
the hardest of the tiles I'm going to show you;
I've never found one. Myself when live playing.
So this one I- I back constructed. And the interesting thing though
is that the tiles are really fun to play with
even if you're not playing by the rules so to
speak, just because you learned so much about
how these permutations work. So I would agree,
I think this is the hardest of the tiles that
we have.
- (So for my- so if if you've got a bunch
of them in front of you even you can't see the paths?)
Yeah. There are other people who are better
than I am. So I have seen students or othercolleagues
um find sets in this. But let me show you the other
tiles because I think they're actually- they get
more complicated mathematically but actually
easier to play. So the next one we have here
- I have them on paper first. We have two games at
the same time of our original S3 set. So the red
and the blue games don't know anything about each
other, you're just playing red and blue at the same
time which makes it a lot harder. And so to win you
have to have a simultaneous set on top and bottom.
Crazy. Now I have seen people find these sets live
but you can see the tiles; and again if you look
really closely you'll notice that there are wedges
at the top and the bottom to- again that really
helps when you're looking for these. You can join
them together, so you'll notice like this one this
bottom has the little circle here and this one
has a little diamond up top and that corresponds
to the fact that they're transpositions. And then
just to see how they combine, these ones if you
combine these two you get this. And so for this one
I actually just have a set pre-done so we won't
even be looking for it, we can just see because I
think these are really hard. Although I will say
some people find these really fast. So if you
look here on the top we trace along, we get our
top line works, our second line works, and then
we automatically get our third line for free
if we have the right number of wedges. And then
similarly for the bottom hopefully this is a set,
yep, yep, okay. We might call this S3 cross S3 set
which is saying that we have two copies of our
S3 set and they're independent of each other so
there's no relationship between the two. So now
we actually come to my favorite version of this,
it's called wreath product set and it was actually
suggested by Josh Mundinger at a summer program
that I work at. These cards look very similar to
our ones before, so recall these were our S3 cards.
So you'll notice they have the same sort of S3
permutation but now they have these blue dots as
well. The rule is that if you have two marbles on a
strand they cancel out. So every time you have two
marbles they cancel out. So if we wanted to combine
these cards, I claim it's equal to this card over
here - so let's see why. Well on our first strand we
come across, it starts and ends in the 1 position
so it goes straight across, and the two marbles
cancel out so there's no marble left. The second
line it goes across, up, back down to the third
position, so we have 2 going to 3 and there's
one marble. And then the third line goes up to 2
and across so the third line goes from 3
to 2 and it has three marbles so we cancel- we
cancel out. So to find a set in these cards we want
the identity permutation in S3 plus an even number
of marbles on each strand. Snd so these tiles I
think are very pleasing, the way that they're laser
cut out. So again you see the marbles are these
holes on the right side, the wedges are still there,
so I have a deal for us. Now I say this is partly
my favorite because this one is actually playable
I think in terms of just staring at it for a
little while. So to save us time I think 2, 3,
um 5, and 7 make a set. So if we combine
those together then we have 1, it goes down
to the bottom, across, back up, two marbles. 2 goes
back to its starting place, two marbles. 3 goes
up down to its starting place and two marbles - so
that would be a set here. What's really interesting
about this, going back again to your question
about playability, is that this game of S4 right
is actually equivalent to a subset of these
wreath product tiles. So it lives inside this
game but somehow this game with- with our dot is
way more easy to keep track of in your eye. Like
it's way easier to play compared to this; I find
this impossible. These are I find quite fun. And
so I think another fun aspect of these is just
when you're trying to learn about these types
of groups mathematically you learn all sorts
of properties just from playing with the tiles.
If you look on the website there are some
versions back to this original game of Set,
some twists on that, as well as some other
visualizations of games that already exist.
Yeah video description.
- (We'll have a link)
- And I also should sayfor me as a math educator I think one of the
biggest utilities of these games besides being
fun is they have been really helpful for me in
the classroom I think. Where just when you're
starting to get familiar with these types of
more abstract ideas in math it's really
helpful. For example with these wreath
product sets it's a really nice visualization
of what's called a semi-direct product and so
I think the exercise of writing out the math
to go along with the tiles you learn so much.